all of the information i am about to
share in this video will be confirmed if
it does eventually get deleted
why don't you tell me what you think
you're doing and then
i'm taking you to the queen
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video well my
friends it looks like hbo is facing the
same issue they did during the final
seasons of game of thrones once again
someone who must work on the inside at
hbo has went over on reddit and shared
nearly everything that happens in the
first season of house of the dragon only
weeks before it airs on hbo max now for
those of you that don't know this same
exact thing happened during season 7 and
season 8 of game of thrones
unfortunately it does seem like this
happens every single year no matter what
they do to try to avoid it i guess when
you're making a show this massive with
hundreds or even thousands of workers on
different sites and locations it would
be very difficult to monitor every
single one of them now usually whenever
something like this happens i always do
wonder if someone is making everything
up it certainly would not be the first
time someone went online and lied about
everything by saying they knew what
would happen in the following season
when i first heard about this new leak i
initially thought that it might be fake
like many of the others i've seen over
the years however that thought
immediately faded away once i started
reading the things that were being said
on this reddit thread now if you go and
look where this was uploaded on reddit
the very first thing you will notice is
that reddit's very own legal operations
team has had it deleted from their site
not only that but if you look at what
the moderator said they also believe the
leaks are very accurate the moderator on
this thread said the leaks seem to be
confirmed by the dmca strikes on the
other things this reddit user has shared
they are working to find out what is
wrong if anything with sharing this
information on the site now another very
interesting thing i noticed is what
happened whenever you try to go to the
original uploader's homepage
the reddit user who shared all of this
information goes by the name of house of
the dragon leaks the account for house
of the dragon leaks has been suspended
now you have to keep in mind they shared
this information only 6 days ago so it
hasn't been on reddit for very long not
only was it deleted by reddit's very own
legal team but their account was shut
down as well this makes me think that
someone is obviously going out of their
way to make sure this information isn't
readily available for the whole internet
to see now that doesn't mean you still
can't find out what will happen during
this first season of house of the dragon
all you gotta do is scroll down and read
what everyone is saying in this thread
although the original uploaders account
is suspended you can still read most of
their comments in the thread you don't
have to scroll down very far or read
very much before you start learning what
will be shown in house of the dragon's
first season
now normally i would show you what it
says and read everything myself but
since it looks like someone is actively
hiding this information i don't want to
get my video removed either i mean hell
they might even delete my video anyway
although i'm not actually showing you
what it says
for the simple fact that i'm shining a
light on this might get me into hot
water either way if my video does get
deleted that will confirm everything
that has been said
now that we're only like 13 days away
from finally seeing house of the dragon
i would not recommend reading what it
says on the reddit thread we're about to
find out what will happen soon enough
however if any of you do want to go and
read everything for yourself then all
you have to do is follow the link that
is down below
since it's already up on the internet
for everyone to see i don't think my
video should get deleted for sharing it
with you i mean it's not like i'm the
one who's sneaking into hbo's offices
and stealing the information i'm only
discussing something that's already out
there on reddit i guess i will see how
hbo reacts to this video soon enough as
always i want to thank everyone for
watching the video i will be releasing a
new video every day this week so i hope
i will see all of you back here for
those ones as well have a great day
everyone i will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
for those of you that did stay until the
very end of my credits i thought we
could have some fun by showing you one
of my very first videos i believe this
was actually the third video i ever
uploaded on my channel this one is about
the season 7 leaks in the video i go
over the first episode i remember back
when i made this video everyone thought
all of these leaks were fake i was one
of the very few who actually believe
that all of them were real the reason
why i want to show this video is because
i thought it would be fun so you could
see exactly how bad my videos were back
then
so let's begin with the first episode
it says the white walkers are marching
south on the wall
now that seems pretty obvious
the white walkers at some point have to
get through this wall to push the story
forward
the whole series has been building up
towards this big battle
with
basically mankind fighting the others
and now that there's really nothing left
up north for them to do now that
craster's dead there's no babies for
them to take and turn into white walkers
defends the wildlings pretty much all
the people up there have been killed off
or brought south so there's no one up
there for them to turn into whites
they really have no purpose to be up
there still so they definitely have to
get south to the wall and get through it
to
have this big war start
so i definitely see that happening at
some point i don't know about episode
one but it's definitely going to happen
next season
and it says bran crosses the wall back
into westeros and meets what dolores
said the new lord commander of the
night's watch and if i mispronounce his
name i apologize
and that also seems pretty reasonable we
know brain amir is right outside the
wall at the weirwood tree and at some
point he has to get back south to get
safe
with just him and mirror out there he
really has no protection against the
white walkers which we know are going to
be approaching pretty fast considering
he has that mark on his arm the knights
king knows where he's at at all times
and bran knows that after what happened
at the three-eyed ravens cave he should
be well aware of what's actually going
on
but he may be smart enough to realize
that that mark on his arm could dispel
the magic in the wall
so he could potentially send mirror to
get help at castle black and hopefully
get john up there to protect him as he's
outside the wall that way he doesn't
bring it down but it's hard to say
he may not have time to sit up there and
wait he may just pass through it
regardless of what might happen
so that's still to be seen to be
determined
and it also says sansa and john have an
argument about what to do with the
northern houses who betrayed them by
fighting with the boltons
sansa and lyanna mormont want to give
their lands to loyal supporters but jon
refuses to hold the car stark and number
children responsible
john does it his way and basically tells
the others to deal with it because he's
not going to rule the north the way it's
always been
now that's pretty reasonable we know
john has always kind of done things his
own way and there's no reason for him to
start changing now i definitely think
he's going to stay true to himself
and want to unite everybody still he
doesn't want to kill people you know for
no real reason especially kids that may
not have had anything to do with their
parents opposing him
he's probably going to want to give
these kids a chance to
reclaim their houses and become loyal to
john and fighting a war but i could also
see sansa having a problem with that
because they are the children of those
who oppose john so i could see it
actually going both ways why she'd have
a problem with it and why john would
just want to
you know let them keep their lands so i
give that about a 50 50 chance of
happening and says at the end of the
episode daenerys and company arrive at
dragonstone she goes into the old war
room with the table map of westeros and
turns to tyrion and says shall we begin
now that's also pretty plausible we
definitely know
daenerys and company is going to arrive
at dragonstone or king's landing very
soon
her entire story
has been her wanting to get to westeros
in the king's landing to fight for the
iron throne which she believes is hers
which she believes she has every right
to be sitting on
and at the end of season six we saw her
and her supporters and her fleet and her
army
head towards westeros so we definitely
know she's going to get there very soon
episode 1 i'm not really sure
because a report came out back in
september
or maybe even before that way before the
plot league came out
that daenerys was going to get into a
battle at sea against euron and that's
when he was going to capture yara and
kill one of the sand snakes
so if that happens i'm not sure if
they're going to have enough time to
show her arrive at dragonstone as well
because they're going to need the first
episode next year to set up all the main
characters
and let you know in which direction our
story is going to go so i don't know if
they'd have time to show her fight euron
and arrive at dragonstone at the same
time unless the battle took place very
close to dragonstone
or if it was a very quick battle
we know euron's building a thousand
ships so i'm not sure
if he had all those made in time to get
out there and fight daenerys before she
arrives at dragonstone
but he could possibly send out a small
fleet to try and flank her or attack the
rear to just take out some of her forces
or at least try to kill or capture
theon and yara
so i could definitely see that taking
place
and we know she's definitely gonna
arrive at dragonstone
at some point in season seven there's
already been a bunch of photos that have
came out that have shown her and her
forces arrive on a beach that appears to
be dragonstone just by the looks at some
of the set pieces with the sharp and
razor looking rocks
that's pretty much what dragonstone is
so
i'm pretty confident that's where she's
at in those photos
so
most of the plot leak for episode 1
seems pretty legit
the story's kind of set up for all these
things to take place so i could
definitely see all this happening